127 hours meet Shark Week guys I've seen
a lot of marriages in my life this one
sounds like it might be the perfect one
sounds like the shallows so the shallow
stars Blake Lively a seagull in a shark
no [ __ ] in the shallows Blake Lively is
having some family issues so she goes on
a retreat and go surfing in this
undisclosed location in this lagoon
where I guess the waves are really
tubular then she gets attacked by a
shark and she knows she's stranded on
this rock that's about the size of two
of her land is just out of reach is
right there if she could just get to it
but she can't because there was a shark
circling her rock just waiting for her
to make a move and when she does dinner
time right simple premise that's all I
wanted in this movie and the movie knows
what it is we're really Blake Lively I
mean she's one of those girls where I
felt like Hollywood is trying to shove
her down our throats like no no she's
good Blake Lively and everything make
her happen like Sam Worthington make her
happen it's like whoa back up let's just
have her prove it and we'll see what
happens and to her credit she does a
good job in this movie other Peter
Sharpe was good it's really no one else
to talk about they have a soft spot for
these really suspenseful movies were a
person or a small group of people you
don't want a group to be too big or just
cluttered up the movie or in this
perilous situation in this one location
just can't get out of you know that
movie the ruins I just entertain the
[ __ ] out of me some people hated it I
liked the ruins now you know the taste
you know who the reviewer is who's now
reviewing the shallows this movie does a
good job at building tension with the
shark you know those things out there
you know she can't step into the water
sometimes she has to step off the rock
and just you know it's coming every time
she starts reaching for something or
stepping off that rock you're like get
shipped back don't to dog down in the
tension building process near the
beginning of the movie they do draw it
out a bit too much before the initial
shark attack we're talking a few minutes
but a few minutes in an hour and a half
long movie is a pretty good chunk of
time be like come on speed it up let's
get to shark attack let's go but after
it happens you're now entertained in a
slow-burn kind of way this movie's going
to be a slow burn it's not an exciting
movie you're supposed to be entertained
in the perilous situation that this girl
is in that you are projecting yourself
into and in
is damn entertaining for what it was I
mean just 127 hours meet shark week but
never as good as either what this is is
a princess in the tower with the dragon
that's keeping her there classic fairy
tale story princess in the tower the
dragon and the knight has to come and
save her but there's no Knight coming at
all this princess just has to get out of
the tower and escape the dragon herself
those kind of girls like yeah what if
Princess Peach was captured by Bowser
and Bowser is going around and his
little smiley face the hover machine and
Mario is just nowhere to be found
because he's off fixing pipes and [ __ ] I
love the simple premise in this movie
the location they chose because like oh
it's beautiful no it's hell for her have
a couple of cheesy parts in this movie
one in particular where she does
something with the shark I'm like I just
don't think the shark would have fallen
for that [ __ ] guys in the end the
shallows entertained me and I believe it
can entertain you too if you know who
you are and what you like in
entertainment slow-burn movie one
location
someone's in peril and there's a shark
circling and she just has to get out of
the situation was it interesting I
thought sup does it have good tension
yes I think the time with it I will say
I had such a good time I had a good time
no alcohol required alright guys so the
shallows have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite one
location super peril shitty situation of
someone who needs to survive the situate
there's a few of them out there come on
scrape for it throughout their
survivalist movie what's your favorite
whatever you think whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
you